Next, let's talk about how to optimize your textures.
So here we'll talk about a few settings that you can use for when you import textures into Unreal Engine.
And so the first thing being that in HMI, you should use a max texture size of 2048, but 1024 is better.
So you can see that we've got a few different settings on our texture images here,
but max texture, especially on mobile, should really be 2048.
1024 is more ideal.
Again, it depends on your project and what you really want to emphasize in your project settings.
So having your textures in a power of two means that they can pack into memory more efficiently.
So Unreal Engine will always want you to import textures.
You can see the series of numbers here in some form of power of two.
The textures don't have to be square, but they do need to maintain this kind of ratio.
So you can import non power of two textures, but you will lose all the performance benefits and optimization.
So if you don't import power of two textures, you won't get any texture streaming.
You won't get any MIP mapping.
And then any non power of two textures will also be full resolution at all times.
So there's no performance gain if you don't import the power of two.
So non power of two textures will perform poorly on mobile devices and it will pack into memory less efficiently.
So just keeping these things in mind when you're creating your textures.
Next, we'll talk about texture compression settings.
So in HMI, you should use a variety of different texture compression settings
dependent on the texture that you're trying to import.
So every texture that you import will be compressed in some way
unless you tell Unreal Engine not to compress it in a certain way.
So we apply texture compression to textures to lessen the memory footprint of the project across a variety of platforms.
So most textures are going to be either DXT1, which is the default by Unreal Engine.
As you can see at the top there, the default DXT1 essentially just means it's not got an alpha.
If it comes in at DXT5, it means it's got an alpha channel assigned to it.
So changing the compression settings will also change other settings for the texture.
So sRGB will be disabled or remain enabled depending on how you've compressed that texture.
So taking an example on the normal map settings, we will, if we set a normal map compression,
it will disable the sRGB as gamma correction. It's just not needed for normal maps.
So for HMI, the following texture compression methods should be used.
So we've got our normal maps. We've got a cube map, IBL or HDR.
We've got the EXR that will need to have their MIP maps manually set to off.
So if you are doing EXR, just make sure you turn those MIP maps off.
We've got grayscale on the right hand side here to help with banding, but make sure you use this sparingly.
And then we've also got UI texture compression setting.
It's more important to make sure that the UI texture size can be divided by four with no remainder.
If not, images will just not be compressed.
So for example, 96 by 88 image would be OK as both 96 and 88, sorry, have no remainders when divided by four.
However, if it was 97 by 89 image, it would not be OK as both 97 and 89 have remainders when divided by four.
So again, it's just keeping these texture compression settings in mind as we move through the projects.
But hopefully that gives you a good overview of the texture compression.
And so let's move into texture groups now.
So texture groups will help determine what MIP or LOD resolution will be shown,
what type of filter should be applied when the texture is magnified or minified by the GPU,
and how the GPU should also blend between two MIP levels when viewing a grazing angle.
So every texture in your project should be placed in one of the texture groups.
So the existing groups are named in relation to what the textures that they control are.
And then the so for example, an naming group would be normal maps for objects placed in the world should be set to the world normal group.
A normal map for characters, for example, should be set to a character normal map group.
So you can change these in the default engine I&I.
So you could also change main engine properties.
But if you go to where your project is on the desktop files, you'll find in the config folder, you'll find an any called default engine.
So you can mod some of these directly from there.
And so they should be under the same settings. Just make sure that each texture is in a texture group.
So it's useful to do this from when your project starts, especially if you're thinking about memory and performance,
we should always be at the start of our projects anyway.
And so you can a few things to keep in mind on that specific point is that you can knock back the LOD bias down to one.
Now that you're once they are assigned to groups, so that they'll be automatically set to the next smaller MIP.
So this can, for example, take a 4K texture down to a 2K texture without even needing to reimport it or change in any of the source artwork,
which is super useful when working directly in the project.
So just make sure that each texture is put in a group and you can save many hours of work and rework even to help the performance and memory at these specific points.
When we're talking about further optimizations and the RGB mass packing,
RGB mass packing is just a way to cut down on the amount of textures and memory use.
So it works by essentially just storing different textures in the RGB channel.
And sometimes you can add them to the alpha channel as well as a texture.
So with HMI, you should not use the alpha as it increases the memory and it's not really worth the extra channel.
So if you are wanting to pack your textures in the material settings, you can then when you have a texture sample node, for example,
you can just pull off the ARPIN and only get what's on the red channel.
Similarly with green and then blue, as you can see, these are all packed into the same texture.
So instead of importing three different textures here, we import one texture, which has an RGB channel.
And you can pull off the required information based on the different channels there.
So really nice way to optimize a project if you're not doing that already.
And then when we talk about RGB mass packing, so inside the material, we then have the RGB pack texture in the material graph.
And then we can just pull off the different pins, as I just said a minute ago.
So you will only get black and white information from each of the channel.
So storing colored data isn't possible.
The workflow is best when you don't really need anything that's super high fidelity,
but you're OK with just this information that you can see on the right hand channel here.
So a few settings to keep in mind, you want to disable sRGB on your RGB pack texture so they are not gamma corrected.
And then make sure that your texture sampler is set, the type is set to masks.
Next up, we have MIP mapping.
And essentially you can think of MIP mapping as level of detail for your texture.
So MIP maps generation happens during when you import the texture into Unreal Engine,
and it just creates a MIP map chain for that texture.
So the MIP map chain consists of multiple levels of the same image.
Each image is then half the resolution of the level before, as you can see in the image.
So essentially as a texture gets further and further away, it will use a smaller MIP map.
So if you are very close up to a certain texture, say we're working with 4K textures,
which we wouldn't be in this instance, but to just give you the wide range of scale.
So there'd be no reason to display a 4K texture when that object is taking up, you know,
maybe a hundred pixels on the screen in the background.
So most of the time you're seeing the second or third MIP.
So the first MIP is only really ever shown when the camera is extremely close to the texture,
and then it stacks back from there as you pull the camera further back.
So there's nothing you need to do to set this up.
Unreal handles all of this behind the scenes for you.
And if you do have any MIPs that you see that are shimmering,
you can adjust the way the MIPs are generated in the MIP Gen settings.
So when we talk about the settings, there's three that you want to keep in mind here.
Simple average, which uses a two by two kernel size.
You've got sharpen, which uses an eight by eight kernel
and some negative weights to sharpen in addition to a four by four Gaussian kernel.
And then sharpen zero is not sharpening, but it still uses the quality down sampling filter.
So using sharpen values four or five is a good place to start testing
and check your MIP issues based on that.
And then here you can see a visualization.
It's an example of how MIP mapping looks like in action.
So you notice that the highest MIP is not used everywhere.
And keep that in mind, especially when you start a brazing textures into, you know, 8K and beyond.
Just making sure that the real estate that's on the screen,
the objects that you're wanting to look at, have the relevant MIPs assigned to it
just to get that the most performance out of your scene there.